this job try saves many people as we can
sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
you don't give up
it would probably pretty simple I'm
Captain America period the end it really
kind of speaks for itself
the whole world was wrong about you I
don't know if he knows what texting is I
don't think he has a Facebook account or
a Twitter account I think he really is
just getting up to speed with like a non
rotary style phone I could do this all
day
nothing too technical I mean you
probably want to go to like the movie I
know no no see he wants to actually talk
I think he'd probably want to just do
like a nice walk and talk a walk and
talk he doesn't want to do anything that
involves any sort of like you know
current technology or modern twist on
how to date he probably just wants to
get to know the person so I think he
just take a nice walk and talk down a
beach or something if I see a situation
pointed South I can't ignore it times I
wish I could sometimes I want to punch
you in your perfect teeth oh god I don't
think he has any idea what that is I
think he would probably be appalled by
it um yeah he's he's he's too mature for
that he's like he's like your friends
scary father who you know would never
entertain that that type of behavior and
probably look down
all right I've run out of patience
underoos everyone
you